The road from Japan to Ukraine...
...for the 82-year-old Dewi Sukarno took several days.
Airplanes do not fly to Kiev from Tokyo now,...
...and yet from the very morning, Dewi is already on her feet.
In Japan, Dewi is a celebrity.
She has her own brand of cosmetics and jewelry.
She arrived in Ukraine with a blue and yellow manicure...
...to show support for Ukraine.
Dewi is in Ukraine for the second time.
In 1962, she came to Kiev as the wife of the president of Indonesia.
She says that now the impressions are completely different.
I have a great memory about Kiev.
We saw beautiful ballet, a beautiful theater,...
...a beautiful cathedral, all the beautiful architecture,...
...and it was so painful for me to see it has been destroyed.
Dewi did not come to Ukraine empty-handed.
She brought, according to her, warmth and light,...
...what Ukrainians need most of all now.
Several suitcases with essentials have already been handed out to people,...
...and four more containers,...
...several tons each, will arrive in Ukraine in a few weeks.